looks like Leonardo DiCaprio's romance
with Gigi Hadid is on the upswing it's
everything I could ever ask for the
source tells E.T quote Leo finds Gigi to
be gorgeous super down to earth and
smart they both genuinely enjoy each
other's company and connect over a
variety of things we love it it's great
and the Hadid family is giving their
stamp of approval too quote Bella and
Yolanda think Leo is incredibly talented
and are of course supportive of their
relationship one of my icons I mean
she's like
my life we're always here for each other
I mean my sister is my best friend my
mom's a best friend my brother's my best
friend and you know when we need each
other we're always there and you know
automatically no matter what we have
they just want Gigi to be happy support
her and help her be a great mom Gigi's
such a great mom herself it's a love
like I feel like I grew a whole other
heart I thought that my three children
took my whole heart
I never imagined I could love something
that big and and now I have Kai and it's
just this whole new heart growing on the
side of it that is just so beautifully
strong and and passionate and I just
it's incredible Gigi and Leo first
sparked dating Rumors in September
during New York Fashion Week at the time
the source told ET the two are the real
deal I'm really excited about that since
Gigi and Leo have continued to explore
their romance but they're also keeping
things low-key the pair have only been
spotted out together a handful of times
including last week when they were seen
leaving a New York City restaurant this
is a rare sort of occurrence they left
dinner separately while also trying to
obscure their faces from the paparazzi
it's really beyond their control so why
are they keeping things so private
earlier this month ET learned the two
are avoiding PDA to be mindful of Zayn
Malik's feelings Gigi's ex whom she
shares two-year-old daughter Kai and she
doesn't want to be disrespectful to him
with her new relationship just knowing
you know what the other person needs and
that also comes from yourself and being
able to express that
Leo's also fresh out of a relationship
he split from model Camilla Marone in
August after four years together so
seems only right Gigi and Leo want to
keep their love lives under the radar
for now but by the sounds of it things
are only heating up between the
lovebirds it's just a really really
great feeling
[Music]